okay so hi everyone um welcome back to
cs224n um so today we're get to have the
second of our invited speakers for this
quarter and so given all of the
excitement that there's been about
transformer pre-trained language models
and um all the great things have been
done with them we're especially excited
today to be able to welcome um colin
rafael who's been one of the key people
who've been pushing the exploration of
large pre-trained language models in
particular um he was very interested in
the development of the t5 language model
which we'll be telling you plenty about
today but to tell you
a few more sentences so um colin worked
for a number of years
at google brain including working with
jeff hinton on capsule networks
he then got interested in the
effectiveness of transfer using pre
large pre-trained language models and as
part of the work on that he started in
with together with other people on
building even bigger large pre-trained
language models and doing a lot of
investigations of those um which led to
um the t5 papers that you'll be hearing
about today so welcome colin
great yeah thanks so much for the
introduction and for having me it's it's
definitely an honor to speak at the
legendary
cs224n class so uh yeah i'm going to be
talking today about large language
models kind of in general but
focusing specifically on this model t5
that we released about a year and a half
ago i'll be presenting
five or so papers that kind of should
represent the full spectrum of good
things bad things and ugly things about
large language models and actually i'll
talk a bit about a paper that just
appeared on archive last night so
hopefully everyone will learn something
new today even if uh even if you're
already familiar with some of these
papers
so just to give you an idea of what i'll
be covering in this talk i kind of will
be answering each of these questions in
turn uh in
in the
over the course of the presentation
uh and i should mention that this
since
some of these
papers are new and some of this material
is new this is the first time i'll be
presenting these slides so if anything
is confusing i understand there's a way
for you to ping questions uh to me
through the hosts and feel free to ask
about anything that might turn out to be
confusing
um so yeah the first question that i'll
try to answer
uh is kind of the answer we sought out
to focus on in the t5 paper which is you
know which of the transfer learning
methods people have proposed so far work
best and what happens when we scale them
up
and then after the t5 paper we
decided to investigate
non-english pre-trained language models
t5 is an english-only model there are
lots of languages spoken in the world so
what happens when we modify t5 so that
it's a massively multilingual model
and then i'll talk about another paper
where we try to investigate what kinds
of knowledge and how much knowledge a
model picks up over the course of
pre-training
and then relatedly in a follow-up work
we tried to figure out if the model
actually memorizes training data during
pre-training if it actually if we can
get it to spit out verbatim
entries from the training data set
after it's been trained
and then finally i'll talk about a very
recent work that's similar in spirit to
the t5 paper where the goal is to answer
not what transfer learning methods work
best but what modifications to the
transformer architecture that people
have proposed work best
so just to motivate this i actually
looked through some of the lectures that
you all have had so far just to get a
sense of what you've learned already and
i know that you are all are already
pretty familiar with this transfer
learning paradigm that has kind of taken
the field of natural language processing
by storm but just as a quick refresher
in this style of transfer laying what we
typically do is take a bunch of
unlabeled text data
and we
apply some unsupervised objective or you
might say a self-supervised objective
where you do something like you mask out
words at random and then you train the
model to predict the missing words so
you can see these blanks in the the
block of text in green and the missing
words that you that the language model
will be trained to predict in the yellow
box at the bottom and then after we do
this pre-training for a while we
fine-tune the model on some downstream
supervised task
in this example i'm showing a sentiment
analysis task for movie reviews
and the upshot of all of this is that
doing this first unsupervised
pre-training step is just ridiculously
helpful not only does it usually make
the performance better it often gets you
very good performance with relatively
little uh fine-tuning data compared to
training from scratch so this is really
a very common it's kind of the de facto
standard way to attack many natural
language processing problems now
and i i think you've already reviewed
some of these methods but because of how
effective the transfer learning recipe
was there really was a kind of an
explosion of work on transfer learning
starting in maybe 2018 or so
there's some prior work on other
approaches to doing transfer learning
like word vectors like word to back
some sort of preliminary work that
proposed the recipe that i just
described called semi supervised
sequence learning uh some work that
suggested that this kind of stuff might
be really possible like the unsupervised
sentiment neuron paper
but i would say around in 2018 there was
kind of a string of papers that kicked
off the excitement in the field
including the universal language model
fine-tuning paper held the alamo paper
what we now call gpt-1 and of course the
bert paper in late 2018
and then starting in 2019 there really
was just an incredible explosion of
different methods for doing transfer
learning including new transfer learning
uh sorry new pre-training objectives new
data sets new ways of doing fine tuning
and so on
and
we started working on the t5 project in
late 2018 and we noticed that as all
these methods were coming up it got it
was getting harder and harder to figure
out what actually works best and
and
part of the reason for that was just
because there was so many methods that
were being proposed kind of
simultaneously and when that happens
even when everyone is is working in in
earnest you know with with good faith
you might have situations like this
where you know paper one paper comes
along paper a that proposes a new
unsupervised pre-training like technique
called fancy learn another paper comes
along maybe around the same time with a
pre-training technique called fancy or
learn and paper a pre-trains on
wikipedia for unlabeled data while paper
b uses wikipedia and the toronto books
corpus which is a collection of novel
text
and then the question obviously is is
fancier learn better than fancy learn
well it's hard to say because they use
different sources of pre-training data
you might imagine that maybe they use
different model sizes
maybe they pre-train for a different
amount of time
they use different optimizers there are
tons of design decisions that that come
into play here
and so
given that these design decisions can
make it hard to determine what worked
best our goal in the t5 paper was kind
of to step back and just say
given the current landscape of transfer
learning you know all of the methods
that people have proposed what actually
works best when we compare them in a in
the same exact setting
and once we know what works best
how far can we push these tools that we
already have
and and
how much can we explore the limits and
figure out how well these things work at
scale
and so to attack this problem we the
kind of the only thing that we
introduced since again we're kind of
exploring existing techniques
was this idea of
treating all text problems in the same
format and this kind of uh
approach this dogma of treating every
text problem in the same format gives
rise to our model which we call the
text-to-text transfer transformer
and so to explain this format to you the
basic idea is that we cast every
text-based nlp problem as a text-to-text
task and by that i mean we the model
takes text as input and it produces text
as output so in in things like english
to german translation this is pretty
typical we feed in a
english sentence on on the input and we
train the model to predict a german
sentence on the output
and you'll notice in our case we
actually also feed what we call a task
prefix translate english to german that
just tells the model what we wanted to
do with the input because if especially
if we're trading a multi-task model if
you just feed the model that is good the
model doesn't know what to do with it it
doesn't know if you're trying to do
sentiment analysis or
english a german translation or what
so
this this shouldn't be that surprising
so far you probably learned about
encoder decoder models sequence to
sequence models and that's basically all
that we're doing here
it maybe gets a little more unusual when
we start to tackle things like text
classification tasks so this is an
example from the cola
benchmark which is the corpus of
linguistic acceptability and the goal
here is to take a sentence and determine
if the sentence is quote unquote
acceptable which kind of means whether
it's grammatically correct and also if
it's nonsense or not and in this case
the
sentence is the course is jumping well
and of course courses can't jump so this
sentence is not acceptable
but rather than training our model
through a classifier layer that outputs
a class label or a probability
distribution over
class indices we actually train the
model to output the literal text not
acceptable so it's outputting the this
text string token by token
and it can get a little even a little
weirder we can attack things like
regression problems where effectively
the model is supposed to be outputting a
floating point value
and we actually just do this by taking
the floating point numbers and
converting them to strings and training
the model to just predict the string
and it turns out that at least for this
particular task which is the stsb
benchmark it works perfectly fine and we
ultimately actually got state of the art
on this benchmark so so doing this type
of sort of
float to string conversion with a little
bit of quantization turns out to work
fine for regression problems
and finally you know the the main point
of this is that there are a lot there
are really tons and tons of problems
that we can cast into this format so
here's an example of abstractive
summarization we feed in a news article
on the left and we predict that at the
summary on the right
and again we can really attack all of
these problems in exactly the same way
so we're using exactly the same
objective during training and exactly
the same decoding procedure
at test time to attack a huge variety of
natural language processing problems
and the nice part about doing this is
that as long as a
transfer learning improvement is
applicable to our model and to this text
to text format
we can try it on a huge suite of
downstream tasks
it while using exactly the same model
exactly the same learning rate optimizer
training procedure exactly the same
inference procedure so we can get rid of
a ton of the confounders that i
mentioned earlier
they calling
yeah can you take a second um as we're
as you're discussing like the formatting
here to talk about uh how the 3.8 sort
of regression example works and
yeah just go over that one more time for
students yeah absolutely so
in this particular task stsb the goal is
to take in two sentences and predict a
floating point number which denotes how
similar those two sentences are and that
floating point number ranges between 1.0
and 5.0
so we basically took the ground truth
annotated uh values that we're supposed
to regress we quantized them to the
nearest 0.2 and we cast it to a string
and now we have a string like three
three period eight uh 3.8 but you could
think of it like three period eight or
four period zero uh and we just train
the model to predict that string which
ultimately it's a string it's you know
it's not a number anymore we just
predict a token by token
um so in a sense you can kind of think
of it as converting the regression
problem to a classification problem
because you're doing this quantization
but you also more broadly can just think
of it as converting the regression
problem to a text-to-text problem which
is what we're doing
thanks
yeah
it's a little funky but i promise it
works
um
and great so the nice thing again about
using this sort of sequence to sequence
text to text format is that we can
actually just use the original vanilla
transformer as it was proposed because
if you remember the transformer was
actually proposed for english to well it
was proposed for a machine translation
primarily which is a sequence sequence
task you know taking a language and
sentence in one language as input and
producing the corresponding sentence in
another language and so really i won't
say a lot about the model that we use
there are relatively few changes that we
made to the standard transformer
architecture as originally proposed and
attention is all you need
uh when constructing our our t5 model
i will towards the end of the talk
discuss lots of architectural
modifications that people have made
sense but for t5 for the t5 paper we
really basically stuck to the basics
so the next big question when you're
attacking a transfer learning problem is
what should my pre-training data set be
and because of the internet there are
lots of possible sources of unlabeled
text data one common source is wikipedia
i'm displaying a ton of wikipedia
articles on the screen here
and
in undertaking this project one of the
factors that we wanted to study was the
effect of the pre-training data set
itself and so we actually constructed a
new pre-training data set that would
allow us to vary the size across many
orders of magnitude also that has a
filtering pipeline that would allow us
to control the quality and type of data
that was pre-trained on and i'll
describe how we built that data set now
so the first thing we did is we wanted
to
source our data from a publicly
available source we didn't want to use
some google internal web scrape that we
couldn't release
so we made use of these web scrapes by a
non-profit organization called common
crawl which is really just a
organization that
sends web crawlers out through the
internet and downloads as much text as
they can and every month they dump out
what they call web extracted text which
is you can think of them as websites
with all of the html and javascript
ideally removed
and this produces
text that has a pretty decent amount of
natural language in it also a lot of
boilerplate and and
menu text and also a little bit of
gibberish
but as a whole it's kind of a good
starting point for for constructing
these pre-trained data sets
and then we took a few steps to kind of
try to make it so this data set was a
little cleaner so the first thing we did
is we removed any lines that didn't end
in a terminal punctuation mark we used a
language classifier to only retain
english text
we removed anything that looked like
placeholder text like laura mipson text
on the right we removed anything that
looked like code we de-duplicated things
on a sentence level so anytime that any
chunk of text appeared on multiple pages
we only retained it on one of the pages
and so on and the ultimately these
heuristics were relatively simple but
produced reasonably clean text and i
will discuss later the effect of of
these choices in cleaning that was one
of the experiments that we ran
and so after doing this we created this
data set called c4 which is the colossal
clean crawl corpus
and it's available in tensorflow data
sets
you actually you need to do the
processing yourself which is somewhat
computationally expensive
but nevertheless
it is entirely possible and it produces
about 750 gigabytes of
reasonably clean natural text data
okay so now we have our
framework our model our pre-training
data set we need our pre-training
objective what are we going to do to
to train the model on our unlabeled text
and so
just to explain the objective that we
chose kind of for our baseline
experimental procedure which again we
will experiment with different
pre-training objectives later
imagine that you have a some original
text sentence like thank you for
inviting me to your party last week
and what we do is we basically choose
some words at random and technically
we're uh choosing tokens at random but
for now let's just assume that tokens
are words
and we're going to drop those tokens out
and so we end up with something that
looks like this we for every consecutive
span of tokens that have been dropped
out we replace it with a sentinel token
and each sentinel token gets a unique
index so one of them we call let's call
it the sentinel x and the other one will
be the sentinel y and see you can see
that because the words for and inviting
are subsequent words that were decide
that we decided to mask out by randomly
masking words
we're going to replace both of those
words with a single sentinel single
unique sentinel token
and then the model's goal will just be
to fill in the blanks and so if you're
familiar with the bert pre-training
objective this is somewhat similar the
fact that we're collapsing subsequent
tokens into a span that we're going to
be uh replacing words from is slightly
different
and the fact that we're reconstructing
just the missing words and not the
entire sequence is maybe slightly
different too
okay so
now i'll kind of talk through our
baseline experimental procedure that
we're going to use we're going to kind
of tweak over time
and along various axes to explore the
the landscape of transfer learning uh at
least circa when this paper came out
so to pre-train the model we're going to
take a model that has a bert based size
encoder and decoder so technically has
twice as many parameters as bert base
because there's a bird-based size
encoder and a base size decoder
we're going to use the denoising
objective the sort of mass language
modeling objective that i just described
and we're going to apply it on the c4
data set that i mentioned earlier we're
going to pre-train
for about 34 billion tokens which is
about a quarter as long as burt base was
trained so it's it's not a ton of
pre-training time but because we're
training on we're doing so many
experiments we needed to cut it back a
little bit
we're going to use an inverse square
learning rate schedule that turned out
to work reasonably well in our setting
but it's not a terribly important design
decision
and then we'll fine-tune on a variety of
downstream tasks kind of tasks that
people cared a lot about at the time
there's the glue benchmark which is kind
of a meta benchmark of many individual
downstream tasks like cola and stsb that
i already mentioned these are what some
people might call natural language
understanding tasks but
for the most part you can think of them
as sentence classification sentence pair
classification or regression tasks
we also consider the cnn daily mail
abstractive summarization corpus this is
a sequence to sequence problem where
you're given a news article and you have
to output the summary
the squad question answering benchmark
which is a reading comprehension
benchmark where you're given a paragraph
and you have to answer a question about
the paragraph you can either attack it
in an extractive setting where you
extract the answer from the paragraph or
an abstractive setting where you just
output the answer
we use the abstractive form because it's
a text to text problem
we also included the super glue
benchmark which was a new benchmark at
the time it was designed to essentially
be a more difficult version of the glue
benchmark it has a new set of tasks that
were hard for existing models
and then finally we included three
translation data sets english to german
english to french and english to
romanian translation uh english to
french being the largest uh which was a
extremely large data set in english to
romanian b it being many orders
magnitude smaller
and we're going to fine tune on each of
these tasks individually and separately
so we take the pre-trained model and
separately fine-tune it on each of these
downstream tasks and we're going to
fine-tune for up to 17 billion tokens
but we're going to save checkpoints
along the way evaluate each checkpoint
on the validation set and report the
performance on the best uh the best
checkpoint and note that this is not a
experimentally valid way to report your
performance because you're basically
doing model selection on the data set
that you are the data split that you are
you're reporting performance on the data
set split that you're doing model
selection on which
is not a good way to to compare
different methods but to compare within
methods uh it's uh it's we're reasonably
comfortable doing this
so now i'm going to kind of give you a
very high level overview of some of the
experimental results in this paper uh
this paper is
pretty huge in terms of which is the
number of experiments we ran and so if i
was to really drill into this paper it
probably would take me the whole time
but there's other fun stuff that i want
to tell you about so
but but anyways the point is i will be
showing you lots of tables like this one
and so in these tables on the columns
you have the performance on the various
downstream tasks and in the rows you
have different experimental settings
that we considered
so to give you an example here is kind
of the scores that we got uh
from our baseline which is the exact
experimental procedure that i must
describe that i just described and i we
also ran that baseline 10 times and
reporting the standard deviation on the
second line and then in this last line
here we're reporting the performance of
the same model without any pre-training
just basically only trained separately
with supervision on all of these
downstream tasks
and
just to point out a couple of things on
this table the first obvious thing is
that in in most cases the preach that no
pre-training setting is dramatically
worse so indeed transfer learning does
tend to be helpful the the place where
that's not true is actually on this
english difference translation task and
that's probably because it's such a big
task that it you actually don't really
need pre-training to to do uh to do well
on it we wanted to include this because
if the performance regresses on this
task then that's something that we
should be worried about
the next feature of this table to notice
is this little star appeared that star
will appear any time there's a row in
the table that's equivalent to our
baseline
and another little thing to note maybe
if you're familiar with the history the
score that we got on glue and squad was
reasonably comparable to bert so it's a
decent sanity check you know we have a
model that has more parameters
and but it's only trained for a quarter
as long
and it nevertheless got
comparable performance which using a
similar objective so we shouldn't be too
surprised about that
and then the last thing to mention is
that we're going to use this standard
deviation over and over again so that we
can bold entries in the table when
they're within one standard deviation of
the maximum value for that data set in
the table
so now i'll just make a big disclaimer
which is we're going to compare lots of
different things we're going to run lots
of experiments but we're not going to
tweak any hyperparameters because if we
did
like change the learning rate or or
whatever
it would be just too computationally
expensive to do this for each individual
methods our hope is that this is okay
because we are treating all problems in
exactly the same uh framework we're
always doing text to text maximum
likelihood training so hopefully we can
keep hyper parameters fixed and arguably
if you propose a new method that
requires extensive hyper perimeter
tuning it's not a very useful method for
practitioners
and we'll get into that a little bit
more later when i talk about
architectural modifications too
the other thing i'll say is that while
we did run lots of experiments there's
no way we could be comprehensive just
because there were so many uh methods
out there uh and uh the inclusion or
exclusion of one particular method is is
not meant as a a judgment on its quality
it's just uh is what we were able to do
given the constraints that we were
working under
so the first set of experiments that we
ran were to compare different model
structures so as i mentioned earlier the
main baseline t5 model is an encoder
decoder model and in this case you have
a separate layer stack
for that encodes a sequence and a
separate layer stack that decodes the
target sequence basically it generates
the target sequence one token by token
while attending back to the encoder's
output to figure out what it should
condition on
um the next
setup that we considered is an encoder
decoder model except that all the
relevant parameters in the encoder
decoder are shared so there are they're
basically half as many parameters and
then finally another variant that we
considered is an encoder decoder model
where the encoder and decoder have half
as many layers as they do in the
baseline and that's because we're also
considering single stack models
the the language model and what we call
a prefix language model the language
model is a is a model that uh models the
sequence strictly from a left to right
fashion in a causal fashion it basically
just ingests tokens one at a time and
predicts the next token
and you can actually apply these to text
to text problems by basically feeding
the input as a prefix before you start
predicting anything
now if you just use a language model in
its strict format then you still have to
have what we would call a causal mask so
a causal attention pattern on the prefix
and that's actually how the gpt series
of models treat
all of their problems but because we are
explicitly denoting part of the sequence
as an input and the rest of the sequence
as a target we actually can allow the
model to have full visibility you know a
non-causal mask on the input region of
the sequence and when we make that
change we call that the prefix language
model
and now the upshot of all of this really
is that the encoder decoder model for
our framework turns out to work best you
can see that when we share the
parameters it does hurt performance a
little bit but maybe a little less than
you might expect
the prefix language model attains
slightly worse performance but
significantly better performance than
doing strictly causal left to right
language modeling which is which is what
you see in the fourth row here and
finally having the number of parameters
in the encoder and decoder
is harms performance significantly
one thing to note is that in all of
these cases we're processing the same
total sequence length it's the same
input sequence in the same target
sequence so in most of these cases the
total number of flops required to
process the sequence is the same
even though the number of parameters is
twice as many in the baseline model
so the next thing we looked into were
different variants on our pre-training
objective so the first thing we did was
kind of compare different high-level
approaches uh maybe just training the
model to predict the next token one
token at a time that's kind of a
language modeling objective another
would be to take the input sequence
shuffle it up and train the model to
predict the unshuffled sequence uh or to
consider a mass language model style
bert style objective like the one that
we that we mentioned earlier
and now on on the second step that i'm
showing here the results for uh we
considered a bird style objective where
the model is trained to predict the
entire uh
original uncorrupted input sequence a
mass style objective which is quite
similar
and then a replace corrupted spans
objective which is like the one that i
described at the beginning that we're
using in our baseline model and finally
a variant where rather than replacing
each uh token with a unique sentinel
token we just drop the mass tokens
completely and train the model to
predict the dropped tokens
and you can see that the latter two
options work roughly as well as one
another uh but another pertinent
difference between these these
sets of objectives is that the first two
involve predicting the entire input
sequence and the last two basically just
involve predicting the massed out tokens
and when you only predict the mascot
tokens you have a much shorter target
sequence and so the overall cost is
significantly lower for pre-training so
we decided that that was the best
approach and then we considered other
hyper parameters in our masking strategy
such as how many tokens to mask out
so the next thing we considered were
different variants of a pre-training
data set
in our baseline we used the c4 data set
that i proposed
at the beginning of the talk
we also compared to pre-training on only
on unfiltered data from c4 so rather
than doing all these heuristic filtering
steps we just take the raw web extracted
text from c4 and pre-train on that and
you can see that that does uniformly
worse so it is it does seem to be true
that these cleaning steps that we're
doing are actually useful
the next four data sets were our attempt
to
pre-train on similar data sets that had
been used in password the real news data
set came from the grover paper it's
essentially
pre-training only on data from news
sites web text is this data set that was
used in the gpt2 paper where you only
train on web text that was linked to and
received a reasonably high score on
reddit
and then the last two variants are
either wikipedia alone or as was used in
the wiki in the burp paper wikipedia
with the toronto books corpus
and
you might actually notice that some of
these more specialized data sets we get
better performance so for example you
can see that on the wikipedia and
toronto books corpus on the bottom row
we actually do much better on super glue
with a score of a little over 73
compared to pre-training on c4 and it
turns out this is because uh or we we
conjecture that this is because
uh super glue contains a task called
multi-rc which is a reading
comprehension task on
on wiki news uh sorry encyclopedia
articles and on novels so the basic
takeaway here is that when you pre-train
on on data that's similar to your
downstream task that has a similar
domain you often get a big boost in that
downstream task and that's indeed what
happened here
interestingly you can also see the
opposite effect so if you if you look on
wikipedia on the second to last row
if you only pre-train on wikipedia you
end up doing much worse on cola which is
the corpus of linguistic acceptability
tasks that i mentioned early on and we
conjecture that this is because on
wikipedia has very little unacceptable
text you're basically only pre-training
on clean text whereas c4 has some
ungrammatical text some nonsense in it
and so that actually can boost your
performance a little bit on cola the
last thing to note is that while you do
see some gains sometimes on using these
smaller data sets these data sets are
about an order of magnitude smaller than
c4 so then the natural question is does
it actually hurt you to pre-train on a
smaller data set
so to answer that question what we did
is basically took c4 and artificially
made it smaller so that it was repeated
over the course of pre-training
and you can see here that when you
repeat the data set 64 times
so it's 34 billion divided by 64 tokens
because that's how much pre-training we
did
you actually don't sacrifice watch
performance the performance is roughly
the same
but if you repeat the data set 256 times
1024 times or more you actually start to
see degradation and the reason that we
think this is happening is because
you're basically over fitting during
pre-training and you can get a sense for
the whether that's true or not by
looking just looking at the training
loss you can see that the model attains
a much much smaller training loss as you
repeat the data set more and more times
so the upshot of this is that your data
set should be at least as big that you
don't see significant overfitting during
pre-training
and
later on when we scale up these models
and pre-train them on much more data we
would do
enough repeats of those smaller sort of
more domain specific data sets that we
imagine we would see harmful effects
the next thing we experimented with were
multi-task learning strategies so when
you're doing multi-task learning you're
essentially training the model on
multiple tasks at once and in most of
the in all the experiments i'm showing
on this uh this slide here we're
actually training on every single task
at once so the pre-training task and all
the downstream tasks together
and the most pertinent question when
you're doing multi-task training like
this is how often should i sample data
from each task
so one approach is just to sample data
with at an equal rate across all of the
tasks
another uh case is to basically pretend
like you've just concatenated all the
data sets we call that examples
proportional mixing because it's
equivalent to sampling from the data set
in accordance to how many examples there
are in the data set
the difficult thing with that though is
that our pre-training data set is so big
that its proportion would be much much
much bigger than every every downstream
task and we basically would never train
on any of the downstream data so we
introduced this this hyper parameter k
which is a constant that basically is
how big should we pretend that the
pre-training data set is
the last thing you can do is take the
number of examples in each data set and
scale it by a temperature
the larger the temperature the closer
you get to equal mixing to uniform
sampling from each data set
but at any rate the main takeaway from
this table is that
you can get pretty close to the
performance of separate pre-training and
fine-tuning like we do on our baseline
if you get the mixing strategy right but
ultimately we found that you do tend to
sacrifice some performance when doing
multi-task training and on at least some
of the tasks and colin there were lots
of questions back on the choice of on
the slide with the different data sets
one showing real news and c4 and so on
do you want to take a couple
absolutely yeah so firstly um
if you just look at this
it still does kind of look like um you
can get great results with
more than an order of magnitude less
text than c4 and yeah it seemed like
that's not the message you wanted to be
putting forward um yeah so there's a
little nuance here which is basically
that in our baseline in these
experiments that i've been running so
far we're actually not pre-training for
that long so as as i mentioned earlier
we're actually pre-training for a
quarter as long as bert uh and actually
for us a
i believe one 256th
as long as uh excel net for example so
and when later in the paper we're gonna
pre-train for much much much longer and
in that case we would end up repeating
these data sets many many times over the
course of pre-training and we'd start to
see these negative effects that i
explained on the next slide oh so that's
why you're then doing the repeat okay
someone then asked about that as to why
are you training on the same stuff over
and over again that's the test yeah okay
exactly
and then they're on the data sets
um
so
to a first approximation does c4 contain
wikipedia or uh very possibly many many
pages of wikipedia but not all of
wikipedia um it you know the common
crawl is done by like uh is a sort of
web crawl by following links at some
priority and ultimately it didn't cover
all of wikipedia i don't actually know
the exact proportion of wikipedia that's
included in c4 but uh definitely
when training on c4 you will see some
wikipedia text uh it will be at a
relatively low proportion compared to
all the other uh data that you'll
sources of data you'll see sure and then
someone wasn't quite convinced with your
argument that um the good quality of
wikipedia explained the worst
performance on cola because they thought
well surely
real news that's basically well-edited
text as well and yet it seems to work
fine
yeah it's it's a good point i i'm not
sure you know it could be that real news
because real news has quotes in it or
maybe real news ended up having um some
content from the common sections of
sites
i should say that when i the reason that
they're real news like and web text like
is that these are our own reproductions
of them so they might not be exactly the
same as the originally proposed variants
because web text for example was never
released
yeah but it's an interesting point and
that's that's also why i would say that
it's a conjecture it's not you know not
something that i can make a rigorous
claim about
yeah okay maybe we should let you go on
for now
great thanks yeah thanks for those
questions
um
so then the the next thing after looking
at these different multitask training
strategies uh
is to see if there's any way for us to
close the gap between multitask training
and this uh pre-training followed by
separate fine-tuning and we experimented
with many different strategies here
basically strict multi-task training
doing multi-task training followed by
individual tasks fine-tuning
doing multi-task training but without
any unsupervised data and really the
main takeaway from all of these
experiments was that if you do the
multi-task training first including the
unsupervised task
and then you fine-tune the model on each
task separately
which is the third row here you actually
don't really sacrifice much performance
at all you are you don't end up with a
multi-task model because you're
fine-tuning on each task individually
but the nice thing about this approach
is that you can monitor the performance
on your downstream tasks while you're
doing pre-training and you don't
sacrifice much performance
one setting that we didn't consider is
the unsupervised pre-training followed
by supervised multitask training i wish
that we had run that but we just we
didn't
um
so then sort of the last set of
experiments we ran try to answer the
following question let's say that
someone comes along and all of a sudden
gives you four times as much compute
what should you do with it and so there
are a number of things you could do you
could increase the number of training
steps by a factor of four you could
increase your batch size by a factor of
four you can make your model twice as
big and train for twice as long you can
make your model four times as big you
could train four models separately and
ensemble them or you could do this last
thing which doesn't actually use four
times as much compute where you
pre-train one model and you fine-tune it
four times separately and then ensemble
those and the main takeaway here is that
scaling helps this is you know very
unsurprising especially in 2021
but uh
interestingly it you get significant
gains
whether you just increase the training
time or if you increase the size
so you can see that along both of these
axis we get significant performance
improvements although the performance
improvements are more dramatic when we
increase the size and in particular you
can see that we've gone from a score of
about 71 on superglue to 78 just by
making the model four times bigger
okay so let me just kind of give a quick
recap of all of that and then use that
recap to explain the design decisions
that went into the final sort of t5
models
the first thing is that we're going to
choose an encoder decoder architecture
because that seemed to work best in our
text-to-text format
the next thing is that we're going to
use the span prediction objective which
is ultimately quite similar to the
baseline objective that i described
earlier
we will use the c4 data set because it
did attain reasonable performance but
was large enough that we didn't have to
worry about
repeating the data and seeing
detrimental overfitting during
pre-training
when we scale up the number of
pre-training steps we actually decided
to do multi-task pre-training because we
will be scaling up the amount of
pre-training our longest training runs
took about a month and we wanted to be
able to monitor performance over the
course of pre-training without doing
fine-tuning so we're going to be doing
this multi-task pre-training followed by
fine tuning and then the last thing of
course is we're going to train bigger
models for longer
and specifically the model sizes that we
ended up
releasing we call small bass large 3b
and 11b
the small model has 60 million
parameters it's about a quarter as big
as our baseline which again was a birth
based size encoder base size decoder we
also trained a model that was a large
size encoder large size decoder and then
we created two larger variants simply by
scaling up the feed forward dimension of
the transformer and the number of
attention heads in the transformer you
can see our largest model actually had a
hidden dimensionality of 65 000 uh in in
the feed forward layers the reason that
we did this kind of unusual way of
scaling up the parameter count is just
because
make
the feed forward layers are just
gigantic matrix multiplies and that's
the best way to make use of hardware
accelerators
um
can i just stick in one more question um
someone was asking about um
how
how you did the
multitask training like so was that
sticking
a simple soft max classifier on top for
each task or
so in our case because we're using this
text-to-text format basically we're you
train on exactly this it's exactly the
same model no new classification heads
for every task the only difference is
that each task gets its own task prefix
so if you remember all the way back at
the beginning we say you know translate
english to german colon english sentence
or you know summarize colon english
paragraph and that tells the model what
it should do and then you just train the
model to predict the corresponding
target
cool so uh the last pertinent detail
again is that we did scale up the amount
of pre-training we ended up pre-training
on a trillion tokens of data rather than
34 billion tokens so it's uh it's it's
quite a lot more pre-training although
it's still less pre-training that was
used in excel net i think by a factor of
two if i'm remembering correctly
so here are the results that
and this these were kind of the way that
things stood at the time that we
released the paper um we ended up
getting state of the art results on
the glue meta benchmark cnn daily mail
abstractive summarization squad question
answering and we were actually quite
excited to see how well we did on super
glue
we ultimately came pretty close to the
human score which was a score of 89.8
and we performed significantly better
than roberta
superglue it turns out is a benchmark
that benefits a lot from large models
and so you can really see a dramatic
increase in the model's performance as
we scale the model up
on the other hand we did not obtain
state-of-the-art results on any of the
translation data sets and the reason
that we think that this is true is
because all of the state-of-the-art
results at the time on these translation
data sets used back translation and if
you remember we did english only
pre-training in our model and we expect
that in terms of get making use of
unlabeled data it's more effective to
use back translation for machine
translation problems than to use this
english only pre-training that we did
i should mention of course these results
are now quite a bit stale and and some
of these scores have been uh beaten by
by subsequent models
so
now i'll just quick make a plug that you
know all of our code is released our
pre-trained models have been released
you can make use of them in our code
base they're also of course in the
hugging face transformers code base uh
we made a collab at the time that shows
a pretty
a pretty basic demo of how to take one
of our pre-trained models and basically
train it on a tsv file of inputs and
targets so because all problems are
text-to-text problems you just need to
give the model some input text and some
target text and that's all you need to
fine-tune the model
and and you can make you can actually
fine-tune up to the three billion
parameter model on a free collab tpu
using the link at the bottom here
great so so far we've been talking about
an english-only pre-training model i
mean we did apply it to machine
translation and downstream tasks so a
kind of a natural question is you know
what about all the other languages
why not train a multilingual model and
so that's something that we did more
recently and actually let me just pause
because i did see a couple questions
coming out i want to make sure that i
i'm not leaving anyone behind as i move
to the next
section
sure so
one of the questions is about
the multi-task setting if you
include an unknown task prefix does
anything interesting happen and if you
don't include a prefix what hap what is
it what does it do
so if you
uh if you include an unknown task prefix
or if you don't include a prefix at all
what it will probably do is apply the
unsupervised uh objective because we
actually didn't use a task prefix for
the unsupervised objective um
well i guess i should say uh
what
it's not quite that's not quite true
because there won't be any sentinel
tokens
in the input so what we actually see it
it typically does is it outputs kind of
some related words and some other
sentinel tokens and gibberish um it's uh
it's not very useful it's i guess the
upshot
um we have questions about back
translation i don't think they heard
about back translation in the rest of
the course
so back translation is a pretty
straightforward method the basic idea is
that if i have unlabeled text data in
one language i use my current model to
translate that data
to
some particular language uh and i use
that as training data then subsequently
for my model it's it's similar to self
training if you're familiar with it
basically you're making predictions on
unlabeled data and then using those
predictions to train the model
it turns out to be helpful
yep and then one uh one
uh
detailed question maximum input length
and maximum output length how did you
choose them did you do a study on that
as well
yeah so most of the tasks we considered
uh did not have input length
significantly longer than 512 tokens
most of the time using the tokenization
strategy that that we uh made use of
and so we used a maximum input length of
but we used a position encoding scheme
that allows arbitrary input lengths and
we actually have uh in subsequent work
fine-tuned t5 on sequences of uh
of length 2048. beyond that you start to
get into memory issues because of uh
attention's quadratic memory complexity
but um it you in principle you can you
can apply it to long sequences
and then maybe one last thing if you
have a second is um
talking again about about how
translation again seems to be not the uh
not the killer app for this and
so
uh what's your intuition as to why
translations like does it
but not benefit from free training for
for what reason
i'm not you know i'm really not sure um
i
yeah i i can only conjecture i think
that pre-training helps the model learn
the meaning of words
it helps the model learn some world
knowledge which i'll talk about a little
bit later and that's a that's a very
loose concept
um
i think that for translation learning
world knowledge is not very useful
because everything all of the knowledge
you need to translate a sentence for for
the most part is in the sentence
and
so basically all of the sort of
contextual knowledge style information
that you need to produce the german
sentence is in the input sentence so
gaining world knowledge during
pre-training is not very useful of
course it's useful to know what words
mean
but to a certain extent you that's kind
of the easiest signal to pick up on
during training and i imagine
that would be my guess i don't have any
rigorous proof of any of
this thanks
um
great so like i was saying um we
trained this english-only model and we
wanted to
address the major shortcoming that
really only can speak one language so we
introduced a model called mt5
multilingual t5 and really for the most
part the if you remember one thing about
mt5 it's basically that it's exactly the
same model but trained on a multilingual
corpus and the texted text format is the
same you know we feed in task prefixes
but we can feed in uh content in
different languages and we can do
classification tasks we can do uh
question answering tasks with mt5 in
exactly the same way that we can do with
t5
so like i said the pertinent thing about
mt5 was creating a multilingual variant
of c4 overall the process is very
similar to the process we used for c4
except that it includes 101 languages
that we detected using a open source
language detector
we also
extracted data from more common crawl
dumps because especially for the low
resource languages it was hard to get
enough data
from only one common crawl dump and you
can see a list of the languages that we
include here ultimately the data set
ended up being about 27 terabytes in
size
so here's a distribution of the number
of pages in the mc4 training data set
for various languages you can see our
most our highest resource language is
english where we have uh about three
billion pages with a three trillion
tokens total um the lowest resource
language is yoruba with only about fifty
thousand pages so you can see it uh the
amount of data that we got for each
language varies by many many orders of
magnitude
because of that a common strategy is to
use this sort of temperature scaling
that i mentioned earlier where basically
you sample from data in a particular
language
by using a by scaling the number of
examples in that language by a
temperature and as the and i apologize
that there the temperature here is one
over the is one over the temperature
that i described previously so in this
case as the temperature gets smaller and
smaller you get closer and closer to a
uniform distribution
the net effect of this is that for very
small temperatures you tend to do better
on downstream tasks on low resource
languages like urdu but as you increase
the temperature so that you get so you
basically are doing examples
proportional mixing of the different
languages you do better on high resource
languages like russian
so we took
m
t we took mc4 we pre-trained mt5 again
basically everything was kept the same
we made the vocabulary a bit bigger to
accommodate all the different languages
but overall the amount of pre-training
the model sizes etc are basically the
same and ultimately
got state of the art on some of the
tasks in the extreme benchmark you'll
notice that we don't report results for
some of these tasks that's partially
because extreme is designed for sentence
encoders like bert uh t5 is a an mt5 our
encoder decoder models we did not
experiment with using the encoder on its
own but in order to attack some of these
problems like the sentence retrieval
problems you need a model that can
output a single
vector representation of your sequence
and we don't have that in t5 so we
didn't apply it to those tasks
one interesting finding from this paper
that i'll just quickly mention here is
that
the
this there's there are basically
multiple settings that people consider
uh multilingual benchmarks uh one is the
case the zero shot case and in that case
you don't do any pre-training on a
language of uh sorry you don't have any
fine-tuning data on each particular
language you only have pre-training data
on those languages so you fine-tune
let's say only in english and then you
feed the model some text in another
language and see if it produces the
right predictions
the next setting is the translate train
setting that's where you take a machine
translation model and translate the data
in the english fine-tuning corpus into
different languages and then the last
setting is the in language multitask
setting that's the setting where you
assume that you have gold standard
ground truth data in every language that
you want the model to be able to uh
process data in
and the takeaway here actually is that
the
difference in performance between small
models and our largest model as we go
along the x-axis is much much bigger
for the zero shot and translate train
settings than it is for the in language
multitask setting so what this suggests
to us is basically that the model
learns
a much wider distribution of languages
if it has a much larger amount of
parameters
and it is able to do this kind of like
zero shot task learning uh multilingual
task learning much better when it has
more parameters
so kind of along those lines you know
larger models can maybe fit more
knowledge about more languages
we had another paper where we basically
tried to answer the question you know
how much and what kind of knowledge does
a model pick up during pre-training
and so to answer that question we took a
we basically introduced a new variant of
the question answering task so the
question answering task kind of comes in
a couple of different flavors the
simplest flavor which i've mentioned
already is reading comprehension and in
that case the model is basically given a
paragraph or an article and then it's
asked a question about the paragraph or
article and it has to basically extract
the answer so you can see if it's being
asked what color is a lemon it has to
look in the in the uh in the paragraph
that it's seen and see that it's the
lemon has a yellow fruit and output the
word yellow so this is kind of the
simplest form of the question answering
task
a more difficult form is what people
call open domain question answering and
in that case you assume that the model
is given a question and has access to a
large external database of of knowledge
maybe all of wikipedia so the model has
to do two things it first has to find
the article or the snippet of text that
contains the answer
in the database and then it has to
extract the answer from the article and
so there's this additional retrieval
step that makes the problem quite a bit
harder
but we introduced a sort of third
variant of question answering that we
call closed book question answering the
name takes inspiration from closed book
exams
the goal here is that you just feed the
model the question it does not have
access to an external knowledge source
it cannot look up information anywhere
it could only answer the question based
on the knowledge that it picked up
during pre-training so if you feed the
model the question what color is a lemon
it has to output the model yellow
correctly because it so
so to speak knows that that lemons are
yellow
so this is a good way we argue of
testing the knowledge the amount of
knowledge stored in the model during
pre-training
so why would we expect that to work well
you could imagine here you know we're
doing our normal pre-training of t5
we're masking out words and training the
model to predict the massed out spans of
words
and you might imagine that somewhere
during pre-training it sees a sentence
that says president franklin blank born
blank january 1882 the goal here would
be to output d roosevelt was blank in
and then during fine tuning we trained
the model to predict when the the
year 1882 when it was asked the question
when was franklin d roosevelt born and
you might hope that it kind of recalls
back to its pre-training task and
recalls some knowledge that he picked up
during pre-training in order to answer
this question correctly
so we took some standard open domain
question answering data sets natural
questions web questions and trivia qa
and basically removed all of the context
and trained our model to predict the
correct answer when asked some
particular question and then evaluated
its performance on the test set for each
of these tasks
and in this table we're comparing the
state-of-the-art results for an open
domain system these are systems that
explicitly retrieve knowledge from an
external knowledge source compared to t5
when it's been trained in this closed
book setting you'll notice that we're
actually using a slightly different
version of t5 here we're using t5.1.1
the pertinent difference is just that
t5.1.1 was not multi-tasked pre-trained
it was only pre-trained using on an
unsupervised objective the reason we did
that again is because we want to measure
the amount of knowledge that the model
picked up during pre-training
and you can see we actually got you know
reasonably strong performance maybe
respectable performance the the
i don't want to use the performance
again word performance again the the
accuracy basically on each of these data
sets increases as the model size
increases which maybe a in a loose way
suggests that the larger models have
picked up more knowledge during
pre-training but we ultimately lagged
behind the state-of-the-art results for
open domain systems that explicitly
retrieve knowledge
so to try to close this gap we
made use of this uh objective called
salient span masking from a paper called
retrieval augmented language model
pre-training and sailing span masking is
a very simple idea
the idea is that rather than masking out
words at random in your pre-training
objective you actually mask out
entities explicitly so that's people's
names places dates etc
and you basically just use an off the
shelf named ended your recognizer to
figure out what entities are in your
pre-training data set and you train the
model to fill in uh
salient spans instead of random spans
so what we did is we took t 5.1.1 after
it was pre-trained and did continued
pre-training on saline span masking and
then measured the performance on our
downstream tasks after fine-tuning and
you can see that the more salient span
mask pre-training we did
the better excuse me the better and
better the performance got uh when we
fine-tuned on the downstream tasks and
we ultimately were able to close some of
these gaps significantly and actually
outperformed the best open domain system
on web questions by adding salience fan
masking to uh to t5.1.1
so this just is a message to tell you
that the objective matters uh and doing
this kind of now people at the time
people didn't call it this but now
people call this domain adaptive or task
adaptive pre-training
and and this is a good way of getting
better performance on your downstream
tasks
so i've got a good set of questions here
uh if now's a good time
yes that'd be great
so uh for some context the students in
their most recent assignment
had to make effectively a mini t5 thing
were the only questions that were asked
for from a simple domain so that they
could pre-train on a single gpu and one
of the questions they have is uh how can
we be sure that the answer produced by
the model is not made up
they were asked this on the assignment
as well i think
um
so
the you if you don't have access to a
ground truth answer it's actually very
hard to know um there's a nice paper
that came out after this paper called
how can we know when language models
know and what the goal of that paper is
to make it so that t5 is
what we call well calibrated and when a
model is well calibrated it means that
when it doesn't know the answer it
doesn't output highly confident
predictions and this paper explored
various ways of calibrating t5 for close
but question answering and they
ultimately found that when the model
doesn't know the answer when it's
outputting you know something made up
that uh they could effectively make it
be very
unconfident in its predictions
so that's one way to do it
i think you're you actually are muted
john
great
thanks and then another question is the
knowledge that's necessary for doing
these fine-tuning uh like the qa on
these fine-tuning data sets
um
is it knowledge that is
all present at pre-training time
yeah so that's that's also something
that was explored by a subsequent paper
where it was shown that actually there
is a decent amount of train and test
overlap in terms of knowledge in these
data sets so it's definitely possible in
these cases that uh that the model is
picking up knowledge during fine tuning
and not pre-training however
just as kind of a side experimental note
we find that
the performance of t5 actually plateaus
before it makes a single pass over the
fine-tuning data set so basically t5
will very very quickly figure out what
the heck you're trying to get it to do
it doesn't even need to see the full
training set before it gets uh basically
its maximum performance on the test set
so we don't actually think that uh that
that's a major factor for for these
results
great and then last question how did the
if you studied it how did the multitask
model do
um
yeah those results are in the paper the
results are almost exactly the same it's
just uh it's a little easier to explain
the whole knowledge pre-training thing
when you are talking about t5.1.1
in the interest of time i might
skip these next three slides which are
the the short summary of these slides is
just that the evaluation procedure that
we use is unfairly penalized as closed
book question answering systems if you
want to learn a bit more about that you
can poke into the paper a bit uh it
doesn't really
support uh the main point that i'm
trying to make
in any meaningful way so and i want to
get to some of the more recent papers uh
that and i should be able to have time
to do that um
cool so we kind of answered this
question you know how that how much
knowledge does a model pick up during
pre-training the answer is arguably a
lot
so kind of a follow-up question is does
the model is kind of memorizing this
knowledge right but does it also
memorize do large language models also
memorize stuff that we don't want them
to memorize specifically like private
data like you could imagine let's say
that somewhere in c4 is someone's social
security number
we probably don't want our model to
memorize that and spit it out when we're
decoding from it
and we certainly don't want it to happen
for unconditional models like gbt2 or
gbt3
so in this next work we try to answer
this question you know do large language
models memorize stuff from their
pre-training data set
and
we can first actually turn to experts
and see what experts think and here are
two statements made by the eff and open
ai that were sent to the us patent and
trademark office when there were a call
for comments on on basically exactly
this question
and you can see that in both cases these
uh these organizations basically say you
know
there's basically no reason to believe
that a large language model would output
would copy data from its its training
data set uh openai you know kind of
calls this a well-constructed ai system
and i think what they actually mean by
that if you read their statement a
little longer they kind of say you know
if you construct an ai system
appropriately the ai system will not
over fit to the training data set and if
it's not overfit we don't expect them to
actually output their their uh any of
their training set in any non-trivial
way
so
these are kind of statements that were
hunches and in this work we tried to
investigate more rigorously whether they
were true
and the way that we did that was
basically by taking the pre-trained
gpt-2 model and feeding it prefixes so
you can imagine you you take a
causal language model like gpt2 that
just predicts tokens auto-aggressively
you feed it a prefix and then ask it to
basically predict what comes next
and we're showing here this sort of odd
prefix east stroudsburg stroudsburg but
we found when we fed this particular
prefix into gpg2 it actually output
verbatim an address name email address
phone number and fax number of a real
person that appears on the internet
this example actually only appears six
times on the entire public internet so
it's unlikely that gbg2 saw this address
very many times uh and the main point of
this work is that
yes it does seem like gpt2 at least has
memorized a significant amount of
non-trivial information from its
pre-training data set
so how did we undertake this study
we used this procedure that we are
that's shown on the screen here
we basically consider three different
ways of sampling data from gpg2 the
first is just to sample
auto-aggressively from it uh the next is
to sample auto-aggressively but with a
decaying temperature this basically
means that you want the model to become
more and more confident in its
predictions over the course of sampling
and the last option is to take random
text from the internet and use that as
conditioning to gpt2 before asking it to
generate what comes next
so now for each of these sam for each of
these generations each of these 200 000
generations we did for each of these
sampling methods we want a way of kind
of trying to predict whether it might be
memorized or not
and so we came up with six metrics to
use to give us a notion of whether a
particular sample from gpt2 might be
memorized
all of these different metrics basically
make use of gpt2's perplexity for the
sample the perplexity as i think you've
probably learned
is basically a measure of how confident
gpt2 was in generating this particular
sample
you can also think of it as a measure of
compression
so
these metrics all make use of the
perplexity
either we just measure gbg2's perplexity
for the thing that it generated or we
compute the ratio of gpt2's perplexity
to the perplexity for another variant of
gpt or to a text compression library
called zlib
we also compared via our ratio the
perplexity of the original sample versus
a lowercase version of the sample and
also a windowed perplexity where we only
compute the perplexity over a small
window of the sample instead of the
whole thing
we take the
top uh we we
do some deduplication on the generation
and then choose the top 100 generations
according to
each of these metrics so that'll
ultimately give us 600 possible
memorized generations and then we
actually just do a basic excuse me a
basic google search to see if we can
find that text that gpt2 generated on
the internet somewhere and if it if we
do find it on the internet somewhere we
ask the gpg2 authors was this in the
training set or not and they checked for
all of the examples that we found and
let us know if gbt2 actually spit out
something from its training data set
so just to give you an idea of what
these metrics are and and why they might
be helpful
this scatter plot is showing the
perplexity assigned by gpt2 and the
perplexity assigned by zlib to
200 000 samples generated by gpt2 and
you can see that most of them kind of
fall on this this line there's a big
clump of them
on the right there in gray
but
highlighted here in red and blue are
samples
that kind of are outliers you know gpg2
is assigning a much lower perplexity to
zlib sorry to those samples than zlib is
and what that means is that gpg2 is very
very good at predicting what comes next
in these samples and zlib is not
zlib is kind of a
unbiased source right it's not really
pre-trained on a bunch of data it's kind
of data agnostic so it might be the case
that if gpt2 is very good at predicting
what comes next in a given sequence but
zlib is not that gpt-2 has memorized
those samples so all of these things
kind of in the top left there are
possible memorized samples and actually
we marked the ones in blue that it
turned out were actually in the training
data set and that gpt2 had memorized
overall we found many examples of
verbatim text memorized from the
training data set this included news log
files licenses you know pages from
wikipedia urls and we highlight two
types of data here that we found that
gpt2 had memorized that
in our opinion constitute private
information like named individuals from
non-new samples or contact information
like the example i showed early on
and so you might ask okay you know maybe
it's not that surprising that gpt2
memorized a news article if that news
article appears hundreds of times in the
internet um we actually got lucky
because it turned out there were a bunch
of examples of memorized data that only
appeared on one document on the entire
public internet it was basically a
paste like a paste of a bunch of urls
from reddit from a controversial
subreddit called the donald
and all of these urls had exactly the
same form it was you know http colon
slash reddit.com r slash the donald
slash a bunch of random numbers and
letters slash the name of the thread
now this random numbers and letters part
is nice because it's equally hard to
predict in all cases it's basically a
random hash so we know that that part of
the sequence should be equally hard for
any model to memorize
and what that means is that we can
memorize we can measure
how many times
does a particular url need to appear in
this list of urls because there were
repetitions in in the list in order for
one of the particular gb2 size models
to memorize it
and what we found was that the largest
variant of gpg2 gb2xl
memorized
a url that appeared 33 times
in the in this particular document but
not urls that appeared 17 times or fewer
the medium size model was only really
able to fully memorize a url that
appeared 56 times and the small model
really didn't memorize any the a half
basically means that we could get it to
spit out the url if we gave it some
additional prompting we basically hinted
at what some of the numbers were um and
what this the takeaway of this is is
that we actually by coincidence because
there is this particular document with
this structure we were able to say
reasonably confidently that larger
models tend to memorize more data if
they they need to see example they need
to see particular examples fewer times
in order to memorize them which which we
thought was an interesting
finding so
so far i have kind of
mostly been talking about the benefits
of larger models right because uh larger
models did better on super glue larger
models did better on the closed book
question answering of course there's
this caveat that larger models also seem
to be better at memorizing their
training data set um but larger models
are also inconvenient uh they
are more computationally expensive to
run they consume more energy and they
don't fit on for example t511b doesn't
fit on a single gpu
unless you use
kind of clever methods
so
the last paper that i'll discuss which
is super recent work is
can we basically close the performance
gap between large and small models
through improvements to the transformer
architecture so in this work we take
basically the same strategy that we took
in the t5 paper
where we took sort of the landscape of
existing modifications to the
transformer architecture and evaluated
them in the same exact setting
and there have been lots of
variants proposed to the transformer
architecture in t5 we use basically the
standard encoder decoder architecture
from the attention is all you need paper
that's visualized here but there have
been lots and lots of modifications uh
that have been proposed since the
transformer was released in 2017.
for example
maybe people suggested that you should
factorize your embedding matrix you
should share the embedding matrix and
the softmax output layer you should use
different forms of softmax like a
mixture of softmaxes or an adaptive
softmax
different ways of normalizing or
initializing the model
maybe different
attention mechanisms alternatives to
attention mechanisms like lightweight
and dynamical convolutions
different nonlinearities in the feed
forward layers different structures for
the feed forward layers like mixture of
experts or the switch transformer
completely different architectures that
were inspired by the transformer like
the funnel transformer evolved
transformer the universal transformer
and so on really there have just been
tons and tons and tons of them and again
the goal in this paper was to take a
bunch of these modifications and apply
the same basic methodology from the t5
paper where we test them in the same
experimental setting
specifically we basically tested them in
exactly the t5 setting that i described
at the beginning of the talk where we
pre-trained a a
t5 based size model on c4 and then fine
tune it on a few downstream tasks
i won't discuss that too much more
because i gave a pretty thorough
introduction to it at the beginning of
the talk
and so
here is a sort of a first set of results
that i'll show you
along the x-axis are different
transformer modifications i'm not
labeling which one is which because i
you know don't want to call any
particular modification out
this is the validation loss attained by
the model
for the pre-training objective so when
we do pre-training on c4 we hold out
some data from c4 and then we basically
measure the validation loss uh on the
held out data so lower is better in this
case and you can see this this dotted
black line is the performance of the
baseline model without any transformer
modifications it's you know basically a
vanilla transformer and you can see that
actually some of the transformer
modifications did attain better
performance which was which was good um
but but a lot of them didn't and a lot
of them actually got significantly worse
performance
and and but maybe even worse some of
these
variants of the transformer that
attained better performance were pretty
minor changes like for example just
taking the relu in the dense really
dense layer and swapping it with another
non-linearity so it's a pretty minor
change
uh and and some of the other really
highly performant ones were actually
ultimately more expensive models you
know we did use the same base model it
was the same you know t5 based size
model
but some of these methods like the
switch transformer for example increases
the parameter count dramatically so it
has it's more expensive in terms of
memory some of the other methods kind of
by coincidence
maybe if you make the model deeper it's
not able to make use of its uh make use
of the accelerator as efficiently and so
it makes the
uh the training time and inference time
a little more expensive
so once you factor out the very simple
changes to the transformer and the ones
that ultimately made the model more
expensive along some axis there actually
were very few if any modifications that
improved performance
uh
meaningfully and this is true on the
pre-training task it's also true on the
downstream tasks we considered so this
is the rouge two score it's just a you
know the one of the metrics people use
on the x-sum task x-m is you can sort of
think of it like a harder version of cnn
daily mail via the summarization task
and you can see that the model variants
that attained a better validation score
tended to also attain a better
x-sum rouge 2 score but again almost all
of the variants we tried decreased the
performance
and just as an aside i kind of alluded
to this a little bit there is a
reasonably good correlation between the
validation loss and the super glue score
um although i'll just point out a couple
of interesting points here one is this
method called transparent attention it
re attained a pretty good validation
loss but ultimately a very bad super
glue score which was surprising to us um
the switch transformer which i'll
highlight here attained the best
validation loss but it did not get the
best super glue score um on the closed
book of variant of web questions
the switch transformer actually achieved
merely the best validation and accuracy
and we this kind of supports a loose
conjecture in the field that
scaling up the number of parameters
improves the amount of knowledge that
the model can internalize but it doesn't
help the model reason so
kind of very very loosely speaking again
this is kind of a conjecture super glue
requires uh deep reasoning capabilities
web closed book web questions requires
knowledge intensive capabilities and so
switch transformer which only scales up
the parameter count without scaling up
the processing
maybe does better on this on on the web
questions task
so
this kind of raises a number should
raise some red flags for you
because this is a pretty bold claim that
most of these things don't don't
actually help that much
and there's kind of a couple of possible
reasons that this could be the case one
is that our code base is just very
unusual and non-standard
we don't think this is the case because
the code base that we used was actually
developed by one of the people who
invented the transformer gnome shazier
and it's been used a lot it's it's been
used in lots of various papers it's it's
basically the same as the tensor to
tensor code base and so we think that
arguably our code base and the
implementation details should be
reasonably standard
maybe the tasks we consider are
non-standard we think this is probably
not true you know
pre-training followed by fine-tuning is
is pretty common basically all the tasks
we tested out on uh are have state of
the art results from transformers and
actually we included separately
supervised only training on wmt english
german which was the task that
transformer was actually
proposed on
maybe we need more hyper parameter
tuning
because we didn't again we didn't do
significant hyper parameter tuning for
each of these methods to test how true
this was we actually took one of the
methods that
that we performed significantly worse
than we expected and we ran maybe a
couple hundred trials of hyper parameter
optimization one one of the researchers
on this paper spent a long time trying
to get hyper parameters right to make it
work and it ultimately never worked uh
as well as the baseline method a next
possibility is that we've implemented
these modifications incorrectly to
sanity check this we actually emailed
the authors of all of the different
modifications and asked them to check
our implementation all of the ones that
got back to us said that it looked
correct to them
and then finally the last option is that
maybe these modifications to the
transformer don't really kind of
transfer uh they don't transfer across
code bases and implementations and and
applications and to us at least based on
the evidence that we have this is a
plausible possibility in my opinion the
best way to control for this is if
you're proposing a new modification to
the transformer try to apply it to as
many code bases and tasks as you can
without tweaking hyper parameters and if
it works in all of those settings then
you're golden and your thing probably
will transfer and we think that it's
probably the case that simpler
modifications like changing the
non-linearity
are not so dependent on hyper parameters
and implementation details and so
they may be the ones that are more
likely to to transfer so to speak
so that's all i'll discuss in this talk
i recognize that was kind of a whirlwind
tour so i've linked all of the papers
that i discussed uh on this slide here
of course this was work done by a huge
and truly amazing group of collaborators
over the course of these five papers
who i've listed on the screen here and
uh yeah i'm happy to answer any
additional questions that you all have
okay so thank you so much colin for that
great talk and there was a bit of a fire
hose of information um i realized also
there was one thing i forgot to say in
my introduction so i guess i need to
have an afterward as well um which is
that um colin has now started as a
professor at the university of north
carolina so effectively the university
of north carolina is playing a big part
in this course because it was also the
source of the cherokee data that we use
for assignment 4 for the cherokee
english um translation so go tar heels
um but um
yeah so um yeah so colin's happy to stay
and answer some questions so if you'd
like to have more questions um use the
ray's hand and we'll then sort of invite
you into the um where people can see
each other um
zoom room
and you know if you're up to it it'd
even be nice to turn on your video so um
people can see who they're talking to
um and
yeah uh
maybe in the first instance you should
stop sharing the screen and yeah um if
there's something you want to show again
you can turn it back on
yeah maybe i'll just say while there are
people are still around um
on the point of me being a professor at
unc in the event that there are any
masters or undergraduate students in the
audience who are applying for phd
programs the the application deadline
for unc is actually has not occurred yet
so if if you maybe you want to apply to
another school have another option
you're excited about the work that i
presented you can still apply to unc we
have a remarkably late application
deadline so just just a plug in case
there's anyone who's looking for a phd
and unc is the oldest public university
in the nation and
let me do the full usc advertisement and
i think we have the second oldest cs
department too which uh yeah it's been
it's been around for a long it's pretty
small it's uh it's only about 50 faculty
so
so while we're waiting for someone to
join up
we do have one question already actually
from
yeah hi thanks for the lecture
um
i haven't questioned about earlier uh
when you discuss like
uh
the t5 overstay and kind of uh how many
passes
it took for it to overfit so i'm sure as
to
if you think uh some of the larger
models like the three billion eleven
billion
ones would like to scale before the
players
aren't
yeah so i mean if you measure
overfitting sort of the standard way
where you compare the loss on training
data versus the loss on validation data
we see that even in this in the very
very large models it's roughly the same
which suggests kind of in the
traditional sense that there is no
overfitting one reason for that is that
c4 is actually big enough that we do
just over one pass over it when we uh
when we train for a trillion tokens and
you know you might hope that you see
limited overfitting when you only see
each piece of data basically once over
the course of training so it's sort of
like every time you're seeing data it's
new data so there's not a huge
difference between the data on the
training set in the validation set of
course there is also this notion of
overfitting that's kind of like worst
case overfitting which ties into the
memorization work i mentioned
it does seem that it's possible for
language models to memorize data
even when they do relatively few passes
over the training data set and you don't
see kind of average case overfitting by
comparing the training
loss and the validation loss
sure sorry i was trying to unmute my
video but i can't do that for uh for
whatever reason uh
first of all colin thank you so much uh
this is a fantastic lecture i really
enjoyed it uh i
uh
one thing that
i particularly enjoyed was uh the work
that you guys did
on uh your your training data extraction
attack uh trying to identify uh really
test this hunch on open ai and the effs
part that
these models don't actually memorize
training data um i'm wondering i
actually have two questions uh one have
openai and eff since changed their tone
uh since you actually
or has your team actually published uh
the results of that and have uh they
since acknowledged that you know well
constructed models may actually do this
and two
would this approach actually work for
detecting
other say
accidentally encoded biases towards
like extreme biases which are prevalent
in some language models like would you
be able to create packages
that could simulate these sorts of
attacks on these models and then
determine with some degree of accuracy
um how much these biases actually
are present
yeah so
with regards to the first question i
don't know of any uh official statements
that have been made by anyone but i will
say that actually on the memorization
paper we had multiple co-authors from
open ai so it was very much a
cooperation with them i mean you know
we're all scientists and we're all you
know we all kind of make hypotheses that
sometimes turn out correctly and
incorrectly um and so i think uh
open eyes is definitely
aware and on the side of the fact that
yeah it is possible that these models
might memorize data even when they don't
uh
exhibit the traditional signs of
overfitting
to the second point
i
the way that people have kind of
measured this in an ad hoc way is by
feeding a prefix into the model about a
particular demographic group or or type
of person
and see what the what the model says
about that person
and i think um i think in principle you
can kind of think of our um our approach
as related to that except that we have
this additional step that kind of
measures uh whether the model
is generating that text because it saw
it in its training data basically
because the perplexity is excessively
low for some continuation uh compared to
a model that wasn't trained on the same
data um so it might be interesting for
example if you if you feed the model a
prefix that you're asking it to to fill
in some offensive information about some
demographic group to check whether the
perplexity of the model for its
continuation is dramatically lower
than you know zlib for example and in
that case you might think that the bias
actually uh maybe this like bias that
the model has picked up is because it
saw some actually a sentence that looks
just like that it is training data or if
it's a more kind of uh
loose concept uh that the model has
internalized over the course of training
fantastic thank you very
very much for sharing yeah thanks for
the questions
okay so next stop i guess is
great um thank you for the talk that was
super interesting um so my question is
sort of what are your thoughts on
potentially doing like multiple rounds
of pre-trainings so
to make it more concrete um you know
like let's say you have a task somewhere
like something like response generation
and you that's very bespoke to the
particular response generation data set
that you use but potentially you want to
kind of spruce that up by bringing in uh
some general dialogue data set that
consists of of naturalistic human data
so i'm wondering if you kind of have any
thoughts or intuitions on how effective
it is to maybe start with
um
you know the general internet and then
fine-tune on this dialogue
unstructured dialogue data set and then
fine-tune on uh maybe a more kind of
tightly scoped response generation data
set
yeah so so the the technique you're
describing uh sounds
pretty similar to this really excellent
um
approach that people now call domain
adaptive pre-training or task adaptive
pre-training i was introduced in a paper
called don't stop pre-training uh and
then there's a less catchy subtitle
um
and and the idea is very similar to what
you proposed basically you take a
pre-trained model that was trained on
you know generic text you do
what you might call like intermediate
task training or you do continued
pre-training on domain-specific data and
then finally you do fine-tuning on your
specific fine-tuning data set in their
case they're considering things like you
know find like doing a scientific text
classification or biomedical text
analysis and when they do an
intermediate pre-training step on
in-domain data or even just doing the
pre-training objective on the data from
the task it definitely helps
significantly um and uh and yeah so
that's that's a a very excellent
intuition and um and i think that that's
the most similar method to what you're
what you're describing um it does kind
of raise a clear question that i don't
think has been addressed uh to my
knowledge in the literature which is you
know we usually think of transfer
learning as pre-train and then fine-tune
and now we're doing kind of like
pre-train and then maybe some more
pre-training and then fine-tuning and
there are other methods that kind of
inject other steps along the way um and
so there's this natural question of like
what should the curriculum of tasks be
you know how like
how how many intermediate steps should
there be what should the intermediate
steps be uh what's the benefit of one
domain versus the other how much domain
shift is there uh and and what are the
corresponding benefits and so on and i
think there would be there's a
fascinating line of work that would be
uh
better basically better answering those
questions
great and what was the what was the
acronym um or
yeah so it's called uh dapped or tapped
uh
domain adaptive pre-training or task
adaptive pre-training uh yeah the paper
is called don't stop pre-training which
is easy to remember if if uh you like
the song don't stop believing which is
i how i uh i i don't know if it's an
intended uh reference to that song i
assume it must be i think they should
have done a don't stop pre-trained in
with an apostrophe if they really wanted
to drive it home but you know maybe that
would have been too cheesy but anyways
yeah the paper is called don't stop
pre-training
right that's great thank you so much
yeah absolutely
okay next question is um
i'm not sure quite what they know
corresponds to then
yes all right uh thank you for that taco
really interesting
um i got kind of an open-ended question
i'm really looking for some advice here
so it feels like the recent sort of
headline grabbing advancements in the
nlp industry have been achieved by
building these massive models like gpg3
um with billions of parameters that
oftentimes you know cost millions of
dollars to train
and you know these advancements are
funded by like larger organizations like
google facebook open ai who more or less
have infinite resources in a way right
so my question is um you know as a sole
practitioner with limited resources but
an infinite appetite for learning um
what are some ways that i can
participate in these advancements and
kind of
you know just partake in what's
happening in the industry yeah
absolutely i mean i i i actually totally
sympathize with you and agree with you
uh in the sense that you know most of
the development of these models is
taking place by small groups uh behind
closed doors at large corporations and
that's not usually how i like to see you
know science developed i like to see it
as a community endeavor that involves
you know all kinds of stakeholders with
varying amounts of resources and we're
not really quite at that stage with it
with this work yet um
i do think that to the extent that
people are still releasing pre-trained
models which is true for example for t5
but but not for gpt-3 there is a lot of
work to be done on basically analysis
some of the stuff that that we were
discussing earlier you know even the the
um memorization work is basically i i
would say it's like analysis work some
of the stuff pertaining to bias uh
involves analyzing these models
um and i think there's you know there's
there's so little that we actually know
about how these models work um
and and what makes them useful at scale
um
the uh
that there's there's plenty of room for
for interesting analytical work which
requires significantly less compute
i guess i would say
a couple other things one is that i do
really hope that the field moves more
towards community develop models and
moves towards mob
frameworks that allow people to
collaboratively train a model for
example like in a distributed fashion i
think that that's an incredibly exciting
research direction it's something that
i'm working uh with my students on in my
lab at unc now
and uh and the last thing i'll say uh
and i actually don't usually like saying
this but i'll say it anyways um i do
think that our
uh field often undergoes sort of a
tick-tock pattern where we show
something is possible at scale and then
we show that the scale is not necessary
to achieve the same thing and to some
extent you could argue that this has
happened already for gpg3 in the sense
that we saw gpt3 come along get
outstanding results on for example super
glue with only 32 examples per class and
then there was the paper that proposed
this method called ipet
which i think is interactive
iterative pattern exploited training uh
that obtained basically comparable
performance in a dramatically smaller
model with the same amount of data um
and uh
and you know i i i you can you can point
to other examples uh i i personally like
to attribute the story of attention's
invention to the fact that researchers
at the montreal institute for learning
algorithms couldn't afford a gpu machine
so they couldn't run the giant lstm in
the sequence of sequence paper so they
needed to invent something that worked
better but didn't require such a big
model so they invented attention
of course it's not good advice to get to
tell someone that they should just go
invent something smaller but i i'm at
least hopeful that some of these things
that we've shown are possible at scale
uh are also possible at a much smaller
scale
thank you
yeah
okay i think
there's no one else who's had a hand up
at the moment maybe now's the moment for
john to ask his question but if any
other people have questions um now's a
good point to jump in
i was just gonna ask a question from the
q a and uh came in and asked it live so
yeah well i will say one other thing
just quickly which is that you know uh
t5 i was very like i said i was very
excited that we achieved near human
performance on super glue the model that
came along and actually closed that 0.5
gap is a model that is about uh you know
10 times smaller in terms of parameter
count so that that's like another
reasonable example of i mean it's still
quite big but but at least uh you know
as you make algorithmic and
architectural improvements um sometimes
you can you can close these gaps
well thank you again colin and let you
um whatever have a beer and go to bed or
something
[Laughter]
yeah yeah sounds great um yeah thanks
again for having me it's a such a
pleasure so uh and i should say if
anyone has any follow-up questions they
think of later on i'm always excited to
get emails about this kind of stuff it's
you know this is stuff i i like working
on so
yeah thank you again for the great
informative talk